hey guys my name is just McDonald today
the 27th of April India change into
games for news a slew of official call
of duty black ops 3 details landed on
our doorstep yesterday and here's what
treyarch of had to say the developer
dropped a reveal trailer alongside the
news the black ops 3 is being developed
for current-gen consoles and estate and
it's going to land on november six of
this year black ops 3 multiplayer mode
is going to feature titanfall style wall
running and so-called specialist
characters your compact with their own
equipment and skills these include the
war robot Reaper the outrider who
handles the bow and is able to detect
enemy ruin a soldier with an AoE attack
and stare appear wield a revolver and
the ability to trigger a bonus
multiplier towards scorestreaks 3
multiplayer maps so far include combine
taking place in a remote Egyptian Sahara
hunted which takes place in a hunting
lodge as you'd expect and stronghold
where you'll shoot it out in and around
a Swiss chateau in the Alps Treyarch
also revealed the gunsmith a brand new
weapon customization system that lets
you add 5 attachments to a weapon and
apply custom paint jobs just like you've
always wanted probably for the first
time you'll also get to choose the
gender of your protagonist in black ops
threes campaign check out the shootie
trailer and the relatively conservative
minimum PC system requirements on the
game spot in news is getting everybody
down today Silent Hill has been canceled
officially there's been depressing buzz
surrounding this one for a few days as
those attached to the project including
Norman Reedus and guillermo del toro
seem to suggest it was all over it's
only today however that developer konami
have broken their silence and a lot of
gamers hearts by confirming that salad
Hills is indeed cancelled the statement
issued to gamespot indicated that the
publisher is committed to you
Silent Hill title but this one in
question would not be going ahead this
news comes just a month after we
discovered that had a Okajima who would
have directed the game would be leaving
Konami to add insult to injury the
playable teaser for Silent Hill entitled
ET is slated to be removed from the
playstation store within the next couple
of days finally Batman Arkham Knight has
a new trailer out which shows off its
GTA 5 style character switching feature
that man might have to go up against the
likes of two-faced and scarecrow but
luckily for him the Dark Knight won't be
alone Nightwing Robin and Catwoman can
be seen fighting alongside Batman
occasionally performing tag-team
maneuvers Arkham Knight is set to
feature a jewel play gameplay mode where
Rocksteady say you'll be able to
seamlessly switch between Batman and his
pals as you fight baddies the game is
due out on jun 23 let me know down in
the comments which batman character
you'd most like to players and why you
can have the game start we've got
stories on an ESPN post slamming esports
and a limited edition halo 5 xbox one
that is everything I have for you today
let me know how you feel about today's
news and i'll catch you same time
tomorrow
you